well brian school board trustees will
soon start talks about who's going to
fill the interim superintendent role
meantime questions still linger about
why dr jarrah was let go in the first
place joe muller is live at the district
headquarters with what we know so far
joe
the trustee president tweeted out a few
hours ago that come this thursday at the
meeting they will start discussion about
how to pick the interim superintendent
all this is happening while many people
still have questions as to why last
week's vote happened
with dr jesus jarrah voted out he is
expected to leave his position while
getting paid out his contract that was
through 2023. he is expected to leave
with nearly half a million dollars pta
president rebecca garcia says this is a
lot of money for the district to just
pay out she says it is concerning and
parents have questions that have yet to
be answered like why jarrah was voted
out she worries about who will want to
work for the school board obviously
anybody stepping into this role
will be able to watch our school board
meetings and we'll be able to see the
news coverage
and if it is a local candidate they will
be well aware of the challenges that
exist she says parents deserve to know
more about what exactly happened she
says transparency needs to happen with
this process moving forward protecting
the staff
i got here live dr jesus jar will remain
the superintendent until later this
month reporting live outside the ccsd
headquarters joe mohler live local now